pensemos en europa como si fuera una
comunidad de vecinos tenemos un
presidente que se encarga de poner orden
los vecinos que se olvidan de pagar la
comunidad y hasta el vecino que amenaza
con mudarse si los demás no dejan de
hacer ruido váyase señor cuesta vaya sí
pero en general el buen ambiente y las
ideas comunes son lo que mantienen la
comunidad a flote tanto es así que
algunos vecinos se han formado sus
propias organizaciones dentro de la
comunidad para asegurarse de que todo
funciona a la perfección como sería en
la unión europea o la oeste por ejemplo
pero hay un vecino que vive ahí y que
hace poco ruido tan poco que se ha
quedado fuera de todos estos grupos y
que además no comparte las aficiones de
los demás de respetar los derechos
humanos de sus ciudadanos o de darles
una democracia transparente este país es
bielorrusia y de ella vamos a hablar hoy
resulta increíble pensar que en pleno
siglo 21 en europa cuna de los derechos
humanos y del buenrollismo internacional
una dictadura haya conseguido mantenerse
al margen de la fiesta de democracia que
comenzó tras la caída del muro de berlín
pero en bielorrusia y a pesar de la
celebración periódica de elecciones
alexander lukashenko lleva gobernando lo
mismo que yo llevo viva en esta tierra
en julio de 1994 y en las que
probablemente fueron las últimas
elecciones libres de bielorrusia hasta
la fecha lukashenko fue elegido
presidente por un apabullante 80% de la
población sin sorpresas en bielorrusia
la oposición no ha obtenido ni un solo
escaño en las elecciones legislativas de
ayer una vez elegido lukashenko modificó
la constitución por un referéndum
celebrado dos años después que
incrementaba su poder como presidente en
2004 y tras haber ganado otras
elecciones en 2001 y también mediante un
referéndum suprimió la limitación
constitucional de un máximo de dos
mandatos presidenciales consecutivos lo
que le daba vía libre para justificar su
presencia en el gobierno hasta el
infinito
22 años y tres procesos electorales
después lukashenko sigue a la cabeza de
bielorrusia y lo que es más interesante
su popularidad no parece disminuir a
pesar de la crisis económica que
atraviesa uno de los países más pobres
de europa una crisis tan grande que para
que os hagáis una idea y el orgullo ha
tenido qué redenominar el rublo
bielorruso el pasado julio quitándole
hasta cuatro ceros a la derecha
entonces qué es lo que hace que un líder
tan poco carismático consiga a perdurar
tantísimo en el tiempo
estabilidad
bienes ha habido que lukashenko viene de
una familia modesta y que antes de ser
presidente de bielorrusia fue
vicepresidente de una granja colectiva
estatal es este pasado humilde lo que
hace que los vio los rusos se sientan
identificados con él y confían en que
sabrá defender sus intereses además la
permanencia durante dos décadas de la
misma persona al mando de bielorrusia ha
generado entre los ciudadanos una idea
de estabilidad que un gobierno
democrático no podría darles
especialmente en el contexto que está
atravesando ahora mismo su vecina
ucrania eso y que desde hace unos años
la tasa de desempleo se encuentra en
torno a un 1% por el control casi total
del gobierno sobre la economía por eso a
pesar de la recesión que atraviesa el
país lukashenko es y seguirá siendo la
mejor opción a ojos de los vuelos rusos
aunque desde el punto de vista
occidental sea de todo menos un líder
deseable
mano de hierro
también sabemos que lukashenko no se
anda con chiquitas y que igual que
cualquier otro dictador basa su
permanencia en el poder muchas veces en
el uso de la fuerza por las elecciones
presidenciales en bielorrusia se
saldaron con manifestaciones de la
oposición y las detenciones de cientos
de personas incluidos varios candidatos
a la presidencia en el caso de
bielorrusia esto viene reforzado por uno
la permanencia de la caja de que ahora
mismo se disfraza del comité para la
seguridad estatal de bielorrusia
y 2 el hecho de que la pena de muerte
aún sea legal en el país las confesiones
de los jóvenes se habrían obtenido a la
fuerza aún así ambos son condenados a
morir de un tiro en la nuca bielorrusia
es el único país de europeo que mantiene
vigente la pena de muerte en su
ordenamiento jurídico las autoridades
bielorrusas justifican su mantenimiento
en el gran apoyo que goza entre la
población el 80 por ciento de los de los
rusos se postulan a favor de la medida
pero aparte del apoyo popular esta
medida es de gran ayuda para el
hermético régimen de lukashenko ya que
gracias a ella poca gente se atreve a
hacerle cara a patca o papa como se le
conoce en bielorrusia curiosamente más
que por crímenes contra individuos la
pena capital- se suele aplicar por
crímenes contra el estado lo que en una
dictadura se traduce simplemente por
oposición al régimen la unión europea
exige la puesta en libertad de todos los
opositores detenidos y encarcelados
desde diciembre de 2010 cuando la
oposición salió a las calles para
denunciar el fraude en las elecciones
presidenciales no se sabe exactamente a
cuánta gente ha castigado bielorrusia de
esta manera pero sí se sabe que en 2016
ha tenido lugar la primera ejecución
después de tres años de una pausa que
comenzó por las sanciones impuestas por
la unión europea tras la extraña
desaparición de dos miembros de la
oposición las sanciones que prohibían a
lukashenko ya otras 170 personas viajar
a europa además de sanciones económicas
han sido retiradas por la supuesta
mejora de la situación de los derechos
humanos en el país algo ilógico pero que
podría explicarse con el siguiente punto
de la estrategia política de lukashenko
balanceo de este a oeste
lukashenko sabe perfectamente que la
economía que dirige no tiene nada que
hacer sin sus vecinos bielorrusia es un
país sin salida al mar que depende
totalmente del comercio o bien con rusia
o con la unión europea así que si tiene
que dejar de lado temporalmente a putin
por pactar con europa o viceversa no
tiene inconveniente en hacerlo la última
prueba de ello la entrada en el
parlamento en 2016 de las primeras
opositoras desde la llegada de
lukashenko para tratar de acercarse a
occidente tras 20 años de ausencia la
oposición bielorrusa ha logrado un
escaño en el parlamento otra jugada
magistral del país fue alzarse como
mediador entre ambas partes durante el
conflicto de ucrania en 2014 y 2015 con
los acuerdos de minsk que deberían haber
puesto fin al conflicto lo que le valió
el beneplácito de la unión europea
aunque ojo que hay que recordar que
bielorrusia es un país miembro tanto de
la comunidad de estados independientes
como de la organización del tratado para
la seguridad colectiva que viene a ser
el nuevo pacto de varsovia orquestado
por rusia por lo que por mucho que se
acerque a europa bielorrusia siempre le
deberá una cierta lealtad a rusia aunque
cabe destacar que los primeros que
adoran a rusia son los propios
ciudadanos
cuando se les pregunta con quién se
siente más relacionado a europa tres
cuartas partes de los vuelos rusos
responden rusia algo que no pasa por
ejemplo en las zonas libres de ucrania o
en los bálticos cabe destacar que al
igual que sus vecinos del norte y tras
la guerra de ucrania los bielorruso se
están preguntando ahora si ellos serán
los siguientes en ser visitados por las
fuerzas armadas rusas a priori no parece
que vaya a ser el caso ya que los
gobiernos de ambas partes tienen una muy
buena relación y bielorrusia ya aloja
algunas bases militares rusas a las que
el kremlin puede acceder sin necesidad
de usar la fuerza pero no os asustéis
que a pesar de todo bielorrusia es un
país totalmente visitable y os puedo
asegurar que mins es una ciudad preciosa
y totalmente segura
así que os atrevéis y os hagáis la vista
podéis visitarla y dejarnos vuestras
experiencias en los comentarios un
saludo y hasta la próxima
y suscribiros al canal que mola mucho